l'info qui a fait beaucoup parlé ce
week-end c'est le montant du salaire de
nicolas canteloup europe 1 cette
révélation de mediapart a suscité une
grosse vague d'indignation sur les
réseaux sociaux
regardez le résumé de cette politique
c'est polémique ces cinq minutes pas 15
comme dans cette période de crise
sociale où les avantages et les salaires
sont au coeur de tous les débats
certains chiffres font particulièrement
parlé sur les réseaux sociaux depuis
plusieurs jours c'est un article du
journal mediapart qui fait le tour
d'internet un article qui révèle le
salaire mirobolant que l'humoriste
nicolas canteloup empocherait pour
animer chaque matin sa chronique dans la
matinale d'europe 1 l'imitateur
empocherait chaque mois la coquette
somme de cent cinquante mille euros un
salaire hors taxes que le producteur de
l'artiste tient à nuancer selon lui
cette enveloppe servirait également à
payer les auteurs et les équipes qui
travaillent à ses côtés alors choqué ou
pas choquer le solaire de nicolas
canteloup thd et vous allez où est ce
que vous êtes choqué par le fait qu'on
alors je vous dis c'est pas par le fait
qu'on dévoile le salir on va longtemps
alors choqué pas choquer je tiens à
revenir là dessus je veux pas défendre
nicolas j'adore nicolas voilà et voilà
je vous dis c'est un garçon exceptionnel
et qui fait pas du tout ça pour l'argent
je vous le dis franchement est pas là
dedans mais juste c'est pas le son
salaire c'est ce qu'on lui donne pour
produire des lecteurs et les auteurs et
attendre alors bien sûr cns un énorme
salaire on va partir qui énorme mais
joue plus pour repasser les choses
sachez que c'est la star numéro une de
reprend c'est le seul truc qui marche
sur la haine sur le celtic d'audience 2
e il sait pas c'est pas pour lui 3 même
si c'est énormissime et c'est vraiment
c'est là je vous dis c'est exorbitant
c'est sur facture voilà c'est sûr ça il
donne à sa boîte de production et donc
nicolas dos après ensuite payer tous ces
auteurs et tout son staff
voilà avec ça donc bien sûr c'est
énormissime mais je tiens juste à dire
ça parce qu'ils n'ont pas précisé un
seul dans l'article et c'est des choses
qu'il faut préciser si on veut de
production en russie
jul dumontet touche aussi une partie
exactement les producteurs aussi donc
bien sûr et touche un énorme salaire
nicolas canteloup nicolas qu'on trouve
c'est une énorme star c'est la règle et
on mangera
c'est la plus grande star de la radio
marronniers cyril c'est systématique ça
vient toujours ces histoires de d'argent
qu'on fournit en fait à une prod et à
chaque fois c'est un put et un animateur
on va bien sûr alors moi je vais je vais
demander aux téléspectateurs ce qu'ils
ont pensé aussi vous au jimmy goodchoice
kelly je veux savoir sa décision qui le
dis mais pas ce que je suis désolé ça
reste des sommes à ses fins
extraordinaire même
c'est de l'argent privé c'est pas
l'argent public oui ça nous coûte rien
n'est rien j'ai cru comprendre que il y
avait une de nombreux pigistes qui
galérait au sein d'europe 1 c'est des
gens qui sont mal payés des gens qui
sont précaires donc avant que lui touche
150000 euros
j'aimerais que certains touchent alors
laissez pas lui directement combien
alors 60 mille cinquante mille sabots
l'import j'aimerais que les autres
touches soient pays soit mû un peu mieux
payés avant que lui soient pillés autant
c'est la seule chose qui me dérange
c'est les inégalités de salaires des
médecins mais les chirurgiens qui gagne
80 mille euros par mois et ben voilà
c'est pareil moi j'ai pas besoin je le
plains pas mais les bars à leur salaire
s'élève à luisao cantine en tant que
canteloup gagne 50 60 80 milles boy la
drogue ouais alors moi je voulais juste
vous dire un truc
nicolas nicolas canteloup alors bien sûr
mais on aimerait que tous soient mieux
payés en europe 1 ça c'est pas de
l'argent public mais mine d'or à nicolas
canteloup c'est pas de sa faute c'est
lui nicolas canteloup on lui propose un
contrat
le patron accepte il va pas dire non
j'ai pu sauver il n'a pas volé l'argent
je suis désolé alors bien sûr c'est
exorbitant c'est énorme c'est absurde a
blagué mais nicolas canteloup est ce que
c'est de la faute de nicolas canteloup
même si on a le droit d'être gêné quand
elle allait s'y voit tous ces chiffres
se disent je l'attendais moi je galère à
la fin du mois je vais faire crédit
immobilier et j'ai arrêté lui je le
voyais carrés s'élève la langue de bois
aussi servent alors les gens qui sont
normés légion qu'on paye ici chez h2o
qui démarre et qui sont à à 1500 euros
par mois
vous croyez quand il voit les
chroniqueurs retenu la veritee un rôle
d'animateur
non mais où l'animateur on y voit les
chroniqueurs et qui lisent pas moi toute
la journée je suis en train de
travailler sur les nations du matin mine
de rien ça arrive le à 9 heures le matin
pour avec cyril pour préparer l'émission
je fais des réunions le matin je prépare
les trucs quand on voit les mecs voilà
amaury par exemple c'est un mec qui
travaille c'est un travail exceptionnel
amaury et dernier amaury un coup moi
s'il vous plaît que tous ici autour de
la table est-ce que alors la mort il a
jamais rien dit mais ce que vous croyez
que le mec qui se dit pas franchement
eux ils viennent ils posent leur cul sur
une chaise pendant deux heures et ils
prennent 10 points bons salaires va tête
aux cinq fois mon salaire c'est aussi il
faut soupeser donc
on dit tout ou derrière les ballons on
paye la valeur ajoutée dans la vie on
doute bien que votre valeur ajoutée à
vous c'est pas la nôtre votre salaire
c'est pas le mien on pas une valeur
ajoutée amaury sinon qu'ils viennent
aussi peut d'abord y est là peut-être
que ça marchera mais si on est très
honnête
combien être chroniqueur aujourd'hui en
france qui arrive à bir et dans leur vie
il ya 250 animateurs que nahla boîtier
qui gagnent pas leur c'est vrai et des
chroniqueurs séparé et jose être un
petit peu prétentieux si on est autour
de cette table c'est peut-être qu'on
élève alors je te supérieur aux autres
aussi non mais j'ai pas dit que vous
étiez mauvais mais puisque disait jimmy
moi je leur ai dit je peux le prendre
aussi pour ma société laitière bah oui
mais il ya aussi des inégalités dans la
société il ya des infirmières qui
gagnent moins que vous ayez stoffel
d'inégalités n'est pas la même quand on
parle de salles et un convoi le shift
est le cas alors vous avez éclaircies un
peu la situation
cent cinquante mille on sait que par
exemple je sais pas les bourdin &
company gagnent beaucoup d'argent et
finalement on sait pas ce que c'est des
têtes d'affiché qui vont rapporter
d'argent mais là les sommes
moi je les trouve pharaonique on dépasse
à mon avis on prend tout artiste libre
accès après son premier opus j'ai payé
la hauteur de ce qu'il rapporte aussi
avec dernièrement alors que là on a
franchi un seuil qui fait que
l'inégalité doit être rétablie lorsqu'on
compare le salaire de l'infirmière à
celle du médecin on n'est pas un rapport
de 10 on a rapporte de 2,3 là je suis
désolé même s'il prend soin at il pas
enfin 1000 euros je peux comprendre que
celui qui en comptera cours en contrat
précaire se disent assez qu'on va bien
sûr mais c'est simplement moi je
comprends tout à fait des gens qui
lisent mais c'est complètement fou cent
cinquante mille euros il ya des gens qui
peuvent que le guen pas en tout dans
toute une vie on est sérieux et je
voulais dire permet c'est vrai on va pas
se mentir
voilà d'enseveli offre il faut se battre
pour un nivellement vers l'euro et pas
vers le bas et qu'il faudra faire
grimper les petits salaires et faut il
n'a pas dit qu'il voulait que le salaire
de comptes loubès on a dit que les
autres salaires doivent adhérer la suite
les jeunes à ne pas dire on doit baisser
c'est à cent cinquante mille euros nous
nous on aimerait moi je suis un peu
comme jimmy wales dit la vérité
nous on aimerait franchement que si tous
bien sûr gagner dix mille euros par mois
à l'entrée les plus heureux du monde
enfin je l'espère est légendaire et on a
envie d'écraser des gens que nous voilà
elle y en a qui gagnent 50 milles et que
loti gagne 5 s'emballe pas
ce qui voulait dire ses comptes où il
n'a pas volé son argent mais mine de
rien on aimerait voilà que les autres
gars vous le dis je le prends pour notre
pour notre société aussi et pour h2o
mine de rien moi y'a des mecs voilà ici
ce qu'ils font un travail exceptionnel
et qui aimeraient être mieux payés pour
la remercier les journalistes iris peut
dire un mot les journalistes qui sortent
ces infos vraies sont eux les sales mecs
juste pour faire des [ __ ] à cliquer
pour qu'on en parle pourquoi je vous
donne un seul exemple une seule fois
dans ma vie
quand je faisais langues de vip avec
avec avec benjamin j'avais sorti que je
touchais 1000 euros par émission sur tf1
pour la faire il m'était fait insulter
des gens qui me les euros pour 2h pauvre
con pas pour deux heures pour avoir
galéré cinq ans pour être sûr tf1 poser
cinq réunions pour la préparer on
enregistrait 6 heures l'émission
donc ça n'a rien à voir avec quoi bardon
qu'est-ce qui vous disent exactement les
gens dans des travers de la wii il
disait il disait deux heures pour 1000
euros
pensez un pauvre con c'est des gens qui
vous connaissez non et akli qui sortent
pas la vérité ou les montants qu'ils se
lavent et or mais on battait j'adore la
phrase de foucauld qui disent un jour
quand il a fait il a fait un ménage
quelque part et on lui a dit c'est
combien monsieur il est dix et vingt
mille euros pour deux heures au lieu de
20 millions pour deux heures il a
répondu non pour vingt ans de métier
il est dedans